on va faire ce qu'on appelle une
préparation bouchée mais en fait bon là
on est sur de la viande vraiment jaune
invariés
voilà donc l'état de la viande elle est
maintenant
à être broyé
[Musique]
et ça va devenir donc de la chipolata
parce que l'épicer voilà les épices donc
on le verse dedans comme ceci c'est que
tout simplement le goût les épices vont
remporter sur le goût
amer est sur le goût poisseux de la
viande et donc le tour est joué
alors Laurent vous aviez même évoqué une
anecdote qui a beaucoup fait réagir sur
les réseaux sociaux et concernait les
familles musulmanes ou juifs qui peuvent
être piégés si par exemple elles
achètent de la viande de bœuf en
supermarché vous avez parlé de qui peut
y avoir vous avez
déjà fait c'est à dire que dans la
machine à hacher j'ai rencontré souvent
des bouchers qui ont fait préparer le
matin les chipolatas parce que il y en
avait plus en rayon parce qu'il fallait
les faire et puis après faisait le fil
américain donc le fil américain sans
nettoyer le l'entonnoir sans nettoyer je
veux dire le matériel et il passait donc
il y avait du porc dans le film
américain il passait tout simplement le
bœuf on mettait la sauce américaine et
ça roulait je disais tout le temps les
gars faites attention les musulmans ne
mangent pas de porc c'est un crime
monsieur mais voilà on en était là
Laurent est-ce que vous pouvez rappeler
je vous avais dit en quelques mots la
dernière fois sur la viande en grande
distribution sur l'avion donc on
distribution les conditions et voilà de
l'avion des deux de la viande qu'on
mange en grande distribution quelle est
la qualité de la viande la qualité de la
viande j'ai en grande distribution
il trompe déjà le client souvent en vend
de la viande la viande allemande je
viens du Royaume-Uni d'Allemagne de
Pologne
et ils viennent et on les vend en viande
française
en limousine en Aquitaine non mais
j'avais ordre j'avais ordre j'avais
l'ordre de mes supérieurs hiérarchiques
de dire que c'était de la viande
française
et puis la viande malheureusement comme
j'ai dit la remballe la rambale
que je faisais tous les matins le
barrage de l'avion les morceaux de
viande était resté au frigo pendant 15
jours et oui on en est là des bavettes
prenez des rayons et qu'on marinait
étire prenait 5 jours de vie grâce à une
nouvelle delc j'ai un pote qui me dit
qu'il y a un frère boucher qui dit si tu
as toute cette viande de non-vendue qui
reste dans ton frigo c'est toi qui sait
pas gérer ton stock et qui en commode
beaucoup trop aussi alors je vais
répondre je vais lui répondre tout de
suite moi je suis simple boucher j'étais
là pourrai exécuter les ordres
excusez-moi tous les bouchers ne sont
pas des [__] c'est pas ce que je veux
dire mon beau-frère Philippe a été
bouché toute sa vie et les bougies et
non mais il est il était bouché il était
chez un artisan mon beau-frère Philippe
j'ai un artisan aussi non mais pour vous
dire mais non mais moi j'étais là pour
dans la grande surface pour exécuter les
ordres
et il y a pas un chef j'ai bien dit pas
un chef avec qui je n'ai pas fait de la
remballe et de la saloperie il y en a
pas un et c'est pour ça que j'ai écrit
entendre saloperies
alors il y a Michael qui est avec nous
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ceux qui
disent que la viande de supermarché et
dangereuse je pense ça fait 20 ans
qu'ils ont pas mis les pieds dans un
supermarché vous vous avez travaillé
pendant longtemps dans la grande
distribution alors je suis issu de
l'artisanat donc bushi
traditionnels de petits villages et
suite à ça après j'ai fait toute ma
carrière en grande surface donc du début
employé en boucherie ensuite second chef
boucher manager manager 1 2 3 4 bien sûr
et les pratiques qui dénoncent je dis
pas qu'ils n'ont pas existé mais dans
les années 80 90
moi j'ai travaillé dans les années 80
j'ai travaillé dans les années les
dernières années
en quelle année comment j'ai terminé au
mois de mai j'ai été viré pour ça donc
Cyril j'ai mes feuilles de salaire hein
parce qu'on me dit que ça gagne pas 1350
balles non non non j'ai les preuves j'ai
les preuves j'ai mes contrats de travail
j'ai désattations des attestations
d'employés de supermarché monsieur qui
venait et je disais signe moi cette
[__] de papier on va mettre quelqu'un
sur le carreau et la faire butner ça m'a
tué parce que il y a des gosses qui sont
morts c'est trois millions monsieur
d'intensification alimentaire en France
c'est plus de 60 décès mais c'est pas la
tête c'est pas la grande distribution
je suis un passionné c'est mon cœur qui
parle
comme ça je suis désolé pas parlant
comme ça vous êtes certainement
quelqu'un de bien vous vous êtes
peut-être votre travail
non je me sens un peu concerné et je
peux vous garantir que à l'heure
actuelle avec ses agissements là qui ont
eu lieu on est tellement contrôlés en
interne en externe c'est un faisable
avec les DLC les comptes à matières et
tout ce qui va avec c'est aujourd'hui un
faisable je dis pas que des gens qui le
font parce que vous dites pas mais vous
vous rendez compte les contrôles sont
internes monsieur c'est des contrôleurs
vous croyez qu'aujourd'hui Leclerc a
tout intérêt à ce qui est un scandale
alimentaire dans un Leclerc ou dans un
Super U mais qui il perd sa chemise
Intermarché ça change rien mais ils ont
aucun intérêt à faire ça il risque
beaucoup plus à perdre si un scandale
que de Cyril et mecs pour que ça se
passe correctement et aujourd'hui les
bouchers modernes sont plus de cette de
cette cavaillage je suis désolé
2022 pour vous ce qui ce qui raconte
aujourd'hui dans la viande en grande
distribution les téléspectateurs qui
nous regardent peuvent l'acheter les
yeux fermés tout va bien alors je pense
qu'il faut choisir son enseigne choisir
son boucher son équipe et tout ça mais
ce que ce que ce que Monsieur là donne
en images complète de la grande
distribution et du métier bouché et
boucher c'est aussi un métier mais faut
arrêter on est déjà plus très nombreux
c'est un métier qui est en train de
mourir allez
nombreux moi j'ai formé des apprentis
monsieur les gosses ils étaient dégoûtés
ils travaillaient pour peau de balle et
on les prenait
le salaire c'est encore un autre sujet
je pense qu'il y a des problèmes c'est
des heures interminables et vous n'êtes
pas payé mais les Lego faire ce métier
là
alors après après bon il y a plein de
boucher qui attestent me dire et qui me
disent qui me disent
rien du tout de ce que vous racontez
aussi alors Gilles oui Laurent j'ai une
petite question à vous poser vous venez
d'expliquer et on le sent que vous êtes
un passionné
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas surtout
passionné de buzz je m'explique
qui m'explique vous avez un très beau
parcours vous avez été candidat de
téléréalité je crois on y va il a été
content dans l'amour est aveugle je
croyais dans l'amour et de la viande
[Rires]
vous êtes comédien vous êtes animateur
vous êtes aussi voyant d'ailleurs votre
finir là il est en train de voir qu'il
va te mettre sa merguez votre dernière
prédiction c'est d'ailleurs qu'on va
être anéanti par un virus mortel en 2023
donc j'espère que vous vous trompez je
l'ai lu donc voilà beaucoup de gens vous
parlent de gens célèbre ou pas et est-ce
que vous ne cherchez pas désespérément
le buzz et est-ce que donc si tel est le
cas vous ne tapez pas sur les bouchers
pour faire vendre votre livre qui
d'ailleurs depuis votre passage ici
étant hausse exponentielle dès le début
d'accord est-ce que votre métier c'est
pas le boss je vous réponds est-ce que
je pourrais avec plaisir déjà déjà
Cyril je vous demande de pas me couper
la parole est-ce que vous avez est-ce
que vous avez
combien de temps
est-ce que vous y reviendra pas mon
livre sur la boucherie non non attendez
attendez attendez
est-ce que vous avez lu mon livre vous
savez pourquoi je l'ai pas lu
trop de buzz d'accord
de télé pendant 2 ans c'est pas un drame
RTL oui j'ai essayé de m'en sortir de
cette merde de cette vie oui j'ai
retrouvé mon père mort sur la tombe de
mon frère ma grand-mère de cimetière
j'ai fait une méningite j'en ai chié
toute ma vie j'ai essayé de me sortir de
cette merde j'ai même envoyé ma
candidature à Monsieur Hanouna pour
devenir rubriqueur peut-être vous l'avez
jamais vu j'ai tout fait j'ai tout fait
mais par contre par contre j'étais
bouché je gagne ma vie et j'ai toujours
caché mon métier je l'ai caché mon
métier parce que je voulais me sortir de
cette merde je suis végétarien je mange
pas d'animaux j'allais j'allais non mais
ouais et je vous dirai ce qui se passe
aussi dans les abattoirs mais attendez
vous êtes en train de décrivez
caché votre métier d'être bouché une
honte que vous venez de faire devant
tous les Français pourquoi parce que je
suis pas un menteur parce que les
animaux sont tués tous les jours
j'ai pas dit ça je vous ai posé des
questions
c'est pas quelqu'un dit en moyenne
surface qui sont jetés à la poubelle ton
animaux tu es pour rien et vous me dites
vous me reprochez moi j'ai rien du tout
excusez-moi parcours personnel oui je
suis un parcours personnel et je le
revendique voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je me sens pas bien
incroyable c'est la coupe de cheveux ça
et je vais encore répondre une chose à
ce monsieur il y a dans on est pas
nombreux emboucherie on cherche
énormément de boucher parce qu'il en
manque là-dessus maman beaucoup de
boucher il y a une chose qui s'appelle
le droit de retrait le droit de retrait
moi personnellement on me force à rien
si je estime que ce que je fais est mal
je ne le fais pas
vous allez me dire j'ai besoin pour
vivre mais dans le cas là il y a assez
de boucher tout le monde cherche des
bouché ça ça me plaît pas c'est
dégueulasse la farce que vous repassez
là et ainsi de suite c'est dégueulasse
je quitte je pose mon tablier faites
votre misère vous-même j'ai ma
conscience propre du travail pour vous
avez continué vous avez filmé vous avez
écrit un livre si c'est pas pour faire
le bœuf c'est pourquoi en plus vous avez
la RT personnes on n'a jamais entendu on
vous a jamais entendu dire ah là-bas
c'est c'est une misère rien pour moi
vous êtes complice et acteur ah pourtant
pourtant le rédacteur en chef ici
j'avais déjà envoyé plein de photos
après vous savez vous savez moi je dis
honnêtement et devant toute la France
devant toute la France je dis monsieur
c'est comment
je vous a plu et on peut l'applaudir
tous ensemble parce que continuer allez
dans les supermarchés continuent à faire
à croire ce monsieur qui est
certainement un bon boucher c'est bien
son travail continuer
continuer continuer il y a eu un malheur
chez buttoni je peux vous promettre je
vous le promets j'ai manqué de faire une
mourir une personne à cause de mes chefs
parce que non tu filmes mais parce que
mon chef il vient dans le frigo ils
viennent je suis pas d'accord c'est
ouais et un moment impossible le mec qui
met en barquette le mec qui coupe la
viande le mec qui rentre si c'est vous
si vous le responsable personne ne vous
a mis à côté tu vas vendre le périmé
c'est le supérieur qui est responsable
mais supérieur dans la gestion dans
l'organisation pas dans la magouille
c'est c'est mais là ce que vous dites
c'est c'est on est sur nos dimensions là
vous vous cautionnez vous filmez vous
faites et après vous faites la victime
derrière vous écrivez un livre vous
dites ah ouais la grande surface tous
des tueurs regardez ce que j'ai fait
regardez ce que j'ai fait vous filmez
encore hein et derrière il se passe rien
je suis désolé j'ai pas crédible vous
êtes pas crédible ce que vous reproche
Michael c'est que vous avez travaillé
dans la grande distribution et qu'en
fait
en fait vous êtes
non mais vas-y dis-le
trop longtemps
Cyril pourquoi Cyril pourquoi parce que
j'avais besoin de gagner ma vie un
minimum d'accord parce que les portes
sont fermés
il y en a beaucoup c'est très recherché
donc il dit c'est très très recherché
c'est très très
jeune qui sont intéressés
et c'est très bien payé enfin c'est très
bien payé
il y a quelqu'un qui a arrêté d'être
bouché pour venir être chroniqueur c'est
Bigard
je voulais ce que je réponds là dessus
moi j'ai formé des jeunes dans le métier
mieux que ça les gosses se sont partis
le dernier d'ailleurs en date c'est à 2
ans et demi trois ans le dire mais il
m'a regardé il m'a dit Laurent je peux
pas rester là-dedans ça pue le métier
est pue je suis pas payé je fais des
heures on me fait faire la merde donc la
merde les chair à saucisse
on me fait faire les saucisses on fait
faire tout il m'a dit c'est dégueulasse
vous êtes partis ouais pour faute grave
pour faute grave pourquoi parce que
parce que attendez mais laissez-moi
parler c'est quoi après vous avez voyons
attendez voyons tout ce que je faisais
d'accord dans cette dans cette moyenne
surface
voyons tout ce que je faisais j'ai
prévenu encore une fois la DDPP parce
que partout je suis passé j'ai prévenu
un DDPP j'ai toutes les preuves toutes
les preuves j'ai prévenu la DDPP il
venait pas il se déplace pas il y en a
tué il y a eu un procès par un million
par des milliers d'euros d'ailleurs il y
a eu un papier un papier dans Le
Parisien ou moi j'alertais c'était
boucher masqué euh déclare la guerre la
remballe d'accord donc attendez donc le
dernier employeur voyons une personne
vient ce téléphone a journaliste et il y
a France 2 qui arrive le journal
d'Anne-Sophie Lapix je dis voilà la nana
elle me dit écoutez voilà on vient quand
on vient on vient ils ont fait trois
magasins on est d'accord trois trois
moyennes surface écoutez-moi et ils ont
fait les donc ils ont pris des des ils
ont donc pris chez nous ils en ont pris
dans un autre et un autre et en fait il
s'est passé que ils ont retrouvé sur les
trois produits trois produits trois
produits messieurs dames des bactéries
mille fois supérieures aux normes
européennes c'est à dire c'était c'était
bourré de bactéries et ça et ça et ça je
peux pas je peux pas la venter donc je
la caisse c'est pas puisque il y a deux
il y a 2 ans j'avertis le Parisien
j'avertis l'année dernière encore France
Télévisions j'avertis et ils ont joué le
jeu ils sont venus ils sont venus ils
l'ont vu et alors les contrôles que vous
me parlez des contrôles vous êtes vous
êtes arrêtés
absolument pas avec les licencié pour ça
ouais bah on m'a trop mis sur le dos pas
le temps m'a dit moi j'ai un chef il me
disait de faire ça mais on m'a dit ah
non non non parce que après on calcule
le chef il est là elle est passée où la
viande elle est où vous savez qu'une
fois dans un magasin
[Musique]
vous savez une fois le le le c'est
Christophe maché
quelque chose Monsieur dame ça vaut le
coup je suis dans une moyenne non dans
un petit un magasin de qui vend de la
bonne vidéo
j'arrive le métier est pas là je regarde
sur le plateau de la machine à G pour
faire des steak haché plein de viande
bon ok je regarde et tout l'avion a été
plus froide tout ça et tout je prends le
coup de feu à la poubelle il est venu je
vous le limite hein le mec il est où la
viande
j'ai mis à la poubelle c'est le viande
il est parti à la poubelle il a pris la
peau il a repris le truc d'accord il l'a
pris il a pris la viande il a pris une
caisse il a dit 4 et il a pris un
morceau il a mis sur la balance voilà tu
attends de perte là la viande elle était
bonne sur la mémoire de ma famille de
mon père que tout ceci est dans le livre
est vrai et oui j'ai voulu changer de
métier et oui j'ai voulu tous vous
rejoindre ah ouais parce que j'étais
impactionné je mais attendez je vous
parle
finalement monsieur finalement et
finalement on se dispute pas puisque moi
j'aime les gens et je suis là
aujourd'hui pour les avertir après un
passionné change pas de musique comment
quand on est vraiment passionné par son
métier on change pas à jamais on essaie
de chercher des choses mais on change
pas et les choses ont évolué je suis
désolé les choses ont énormément évolué
les gens en grande distribution il y a
pas il y a un contrôle interne qui est
réalisé par le chef et par les équipes
une prise de température
DLC dans les frigos et ainsi de suite
c'est d'ailleurs c'est bien établi parce
qu'il y a des fiches où on doit remplir
avant de prendre un poste deuxième point
il y a à l'heure actuelle dans la
plupart des grandes surfaces je vais
dire 90%, il y a une fille ou bien une
personne qui s'occupe du contrôle
qualité elle est formée au contrôle
qualité donc elle tourne dans tous les
rayons parce que la boucherie dans tous
les rayons elle valide elle valide pas
elle fait elle fait son tour suite à ça
on a des contrôles de chez agro analyse
selon les notes reçues il passe plus ou
moins de nombreux fois dans l'année si
les notes sont mauvaises il passe
régulièrement s'ils notent sont bonnes
il passe dans l'année
il y a des audits internes donc ils
appellent bonjour ago analyses on va
faire un test c'est un audit pour poser
les questions qui vous font sur pour
avancer et suite à ça on a le contrôle
euro fin donc ça c'est des contrôles qui
sont internes à la grande surface et les
mecs qui passent ils me préviennent pas
ils sont notés les chefs bouchés la
plupart sont primés là-dessus c'est bon
pour aujourd'hui son prix mais là-dessus
donc ils ont tout intérêt à ce que ça se
passe bien je suis désolé ce que vous
racontez je ne dis pas que ça n'a pas
existé
dans les années 80
merci le changement
merci à vous deux merci